warehouse we think about something which
is not sophisticated but it's
it's need to be handled in a very
sophisticated manner
meaning people are walking walking
uh tens of miles a day in the warehouse
to bring boxes and lifts
up and down the boxes and and take the
relevant item
items welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance
opposed hillel at stanford leap and
birthright excel
and in media partnership with c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20-minute
leaders today we're going to be talking
about how robots are completely
disrupting
warehouses fulfillment pretty much any
supply chain
meet hanayanovsky cro and general
manager of kaiju robotics
hannah started as a commercial lawyer in
advising and managing transactions in
the tech ecosystem
her curiosity led her to change size and
become an entrepreneur and tech
executive
and since 2015 has been focusing on the
robotics and automation industries
she is the general manager and chief
revenue officer of kaiju robotics
automating solutions for order
fulfillment
hannah yanovsky welcome to 20 minute
leaders the general manager
and chief revenue officer of cajon
robotics how are you
hi michael i'm fine fine happy to be in
your
in your show and looking forward i'm
really excited for these next 20 minutes
your journey is is so interesting from
being a lawyer
to being vp legal at another company but
now
working in robotics and and warehouses
and
logistics and optimizations i think
that's going to be so interesting
and for us to talk hannah before we dive
into the world of robotics and
warehouses and logistics tell me a
little bit about your own personal
journey
and and how you ended up even in this
space
okay sure gladly um as you said i
started as a commercial lawyer
from a very young age and the commercial
aspect
really um really interested me and
that's why i chose to go to the
commercial side of the legal
award and even from early stage i was
really fascinated from
um what the entrepreneur and the
investors and the companies
were facing and also in my legal
role i tried to address those commercial
matters
broadly and then i took a decision to
switch part
and join the world of high-tech and
business and commercial not from
just a legal aspect but also from a
manager and entrepreneur aspects and see
how
uh i can um
influence and and and and and
be more involved in those commercial
aspects and business aspects and
um i started from across border
transactions and
m as and been in a global company
for the business affairs um and
we had a lot of business not just in
israel but mainly in china
u.s and europe um this was my
journey in the automation and robotic
industry um
and in 2019 i joined caja as you
as you said and cajo robotics uh also
because it's fascinated me
the the the industry the the new concept
and what this company has
developed um it it is i think a unique
combination
that happens rarely of a booming
industry
a real need from the customers and a
real
product it is new and not same as others
and this combination made me realize
that i really want to join this journey
and this company
and try to build with together with the
team
a global and industrial company since
then and
and make the the solution of kaha
becoming more and more
familiar with the market so castle
robotics
tell me a little bit about for before
even before kaha tell me a little bit
about the problem space so
where are we you know what vertical are
we in and
what what big pain point in the world
are you trying to solve
okay sure um and we are operating the
logistic
market where there are customers and the
customers can be
either at the retail themselves
the readers can be in the fashion
industry um
in a pharma industry in other industries
or
a 3pl third party is logistic customers
that
provide services to many more other
companies
were in the same warehouse the same they
have many many items
and goods of different customers and
they serve those customers
whether it is b2b or b2c meaning whether
it
it is something that michael is order
online
and they will send it to michael or
whether it's a chain of company of of
stores
and they will send it to this chain of
so these are the relevant um industry
and warehouses and i'm when i'm saying
warehouses i mean
huge you you look at the warehouse it's
it's like you see
sometimes thousands of meters
of warehouse warehouse it's really uh
something that
until you visit at such a warehouse you
cannot even
think how it looks like and the amount
of goods that they need to handle
is enormous and sometimes they have one
warehouse which
serve the entire and west coast of
united states
so just imagine the amount of good that
they have
for such a retail a footwear company for
example
and how they need to be very very
efficient
and optimize everything um and
they have many challenges in that aspect
because
real estate is expensive right um and
they need to find the
optimum manner to a
to handle the the inventory and to
handle the orders
uh to make sure that they don't do
errors and to make sure they
they handle inbound because all the time
they have a new inventory coming in
um so there is a of course fifa and
other elements they need to handle
it's it sound warehouse we think about
something which is not sophisticated but
it's
it's need to be handled in a very
sophisticated manner
right and another fascinating point
in my in my uh in my view at least is
that until now
95 of those warehouses are handled
manually in the area of we call it order
fulfillment
meaning from the minute that there is an
order
from a from the end user
someone that ordered online or from from
from their
store itself and until
a the order is being picked the relevant
item is being picked from there
from their box the relevant box
after the inventory is placed in the in
the in the
in the warehouse it is done manually
meaning
people are walking walking tens of miles
a day
in the warehouse to bring boxes
and lift up and down the boxes and and
take the relevant
item items wow um
and this is something which is not
relevant for people to handle
in so many aspects um people are not
willing to do that
all of our customers no matter where
they are and
having a real challenge to find a
labor to handle that and this is
specifically a work that needs to be
handled by robots and machine
and to make sure that people will handle
handle different
tasks in the warehouse which are more
friendly for human beings
right yes and and so the robots
themselves so
well how does the solution actually work
robots are involved you're
i'm hearing that you're replacing a lot
of the manual labor
that humans have to do whether it's
vertically or horizontally within the
within the warehouses so where how does
this actually work
and integrate within the warehouses
okay i will explain in a nutshell uh we
have two types of robots
uh that work in combination and there is
a
thought behind those two types of robots
but what manage the entire operation the
brain of the solution is actually the
software
there is a software placed in the cloud
with
a algorithm that manage the entire
optimization of the warehouse
it will anticipate what will be the high
runners
where to place them what is the backlogs
of the orders
when there will be peak if it can be
anticipated
and and other other behavior of the
warehouse
um it has ai and deep learning and
it will uh instruct the robots
uh to where to place the inventory once
the inventory arrives to the warehouse
how to reorganize all the time the
inventory
in the warehouse meaning to consolidate
a boxes to place high runners closer to
the picking station
to a um swi switch between boxes etc
the big up or the lift robots will
take boxes from the inventory place them
in the warehouse
and take them from a high shelves to
lower shelves
and then we have the small robots very
very efficient very very
um fast and they will run in the
warehouse
and bring those boxes to the picking
station wow and the ratio between those
two types of robots
will also allow efficiency and
attractiveness in terms of our
eye i can talk to talk about it for a
half an hour now but i did it really
fast
um and of course there are the picking
stations which also manage everything
smartly so i the entire solution try to
make sure that the warehouse and the
order fulfillment is done very
efficiently
and a very very in accordance with the
specific needs of
this warehouse amazing and so you know i
think
the big question here especially when it
comes to to indoors and robotics is this
idea of personalization versus the
generality
and so one of the things that i'm always
curious about with these types of
solutions
how how generalized are these robots
because you have
and i and i'm not sure how many
different types of warehouses you may
have
and let's say a where a walmart
warehouse versus a foot locker
warehouse you know is it the same robots
how much do you have to customize these
robots to fit the new environment
okay so we have two types of robots and
they we do not do a customization for
each customer but
compared to other solutions we do have a
considerably more degree of freedom or
relatively degree
a lot of degree of freedom because we
have several building blocks in our
solution
we have the software where we can do
some customization and we have the two
types of robots and two type of picking
station
so we will receive data from the
warehouse about the activity
um and we will provide the customer the
configuration and the layout of our
solution with those
building blocks and some personal
personalization
um to address its specific
uh needs and demands um
and our solution in one warehouse will
not look as the
other solution in a different warehouse
meaning at the end we will we will adapt
our solution to the warehouse and not
vice versa
but we will do that with our building
blocks right okay so that that makes a
lot of sense now as you're
more strategically thinking you know if
you if you look at the supply chain of
how this will at the end
impact you know both me as an end
consumer but also the
the company that is that is managing the
warehouses
what it you know how how does this
impact the world in
non-trivial ways you know besides the
really obvious stakeholders
how is calhoun robotics going to impact
the daily life of different people
around the world
first of all i would like to um to
comment that during the coffee
uh at the beginning we were a bit
stressed but then we saw that
the ecom was booming so the demand for
such a
such a solution is only increasing
and i think at the end it it changes the
the behavior of the consumers more and
more e-commerce done
by by by the computer itself it affects
the stores themselves which are and now
operating more and more from the
logistics centers
and less from the stores themselves um
it affects also in terms of the
environment because
you have now one logistics center which
can handle
many types of goods or one types of
goods
for a large large retail
um and you have this logistics center
which will provide
all the service for the for for the end
users
and no need maybe it's good maybe it's
bad but less and less stores
less and less need to use electricity
because our robots can
work in in the dark less and less air
conditioning
and less and less and more and more
efficient way to use
the real estate because you can have
more density
in in the same warehouse compared to
when it's manual or when it's in the
stores themselves
um so i think at the end it will have
a great impact on the on the way that we
will see
how the entire industry of shopping
let's call it this way will behave
uh it starts from real estate uh to
a shopping centers and to the way that
those companies will handle
their inventory and even uh the way that
they will handle shipment
it's another environment aspect whether
they need to ship
everything to one place uh several
places etc
and we see also a trend of micro
fulfillment
smaller logistics centers closer to the
cities to serve the city
but it can be done outside the city not
in the middle of the city
so there are many aspects that will
influence environmental behavior real
estate
and and i think at the end also the cost
of the customers and the cost of the
of the of the retails and the in this
entire industry
fantastic amazing now one of the things
that we we very briefly spoke about
before
was this idea of planning and this is
more about your
own personal journey anna about about
planning and and
you know the the interesting balance
between
you know being falling in love with a
plan versus being open so tell me a
little bit about your own personal story
um and if i need to think about first of
all from
from my personal journey i all the time
trying to evolve as a person in my in my
professional career and i moved from one
one um um path to another
and i only benefit from that and this is
from
personal note but in terms of the
business itself when
i have a story to share
and in 2020 and
we decided that it's the time to start
the sales and marketing activities in
caja
and there was a plan and the prime
market was
a u.s and europe and
we have a company in israel but those
were the prime markets and
we started the plan and i sat with my
team etc
it was in february 2020 in march
everybody woke up today to the covered
and
suddenly we couldn't fly we couldn't
meet customers and europe
was shutting down u.s later on um
and we thought what we're going to do
are we going to freeze all the
activities of sales and marketing we
just started
this activity um and then and
i i decided and i spoke with my team and
i said
let's go and sell in israel we are close
we are here
let's do that and we saw a great
potential also in israel
and we succeeded in several transactions
here in israel which were enablers
to other transactions um and for us
the the plan the plan was changed to
work also with partners
meaning and companies that understand
technology
understand the solution and you can
describe it today to them even
with the video with the teams and not
necessarily to arrive and meet them
and and by this change of concept
we manage succeed to have several
a nice transaction in the us
where we haven't met the customer only
after a year
after we signed after we closed the
transaction
and it was something that on march we
didn't think that we could
we could do um so it it
the plan changed but it was beneficial
at the end
it also made made us realize that the
the
system itself is could be handled from
from remotely which is also benefit
uh to do it remotely so this is this is
an example how
you have a plan but then you have
something so dramatically the change the
plan but at the end it can be also
good results i i
love it and hannah i really want to
thank you for coming on the show and
sharing the story of both yourself and
also
robotics i have no doubt that this is
where the world is heading and
um you know besides just the you know
the way that it's impacting at the end
the people the actual laborers
in in the warehouse it's impacting the
entire supply chain in very dramatic
ways
both in terms of efficiency in terms of
consumer expectations
in terms of prices and and and so all
around
i mean definitely this is the world the
world is heading and i really hope that
is going to be a leading a market leader
in the segment and so thank you for
coming and sharing this journey
and the idea of planning not planning
when someone when somebody punches you
in the face you have to change the plan
and there's nothing else to do
and it sounds like that's exactly what
all of you did with caco robotics
i do have a few last questions about you
and i want you to take me back hannah to
your childhood and
share with me what really fascinated you
as a kid
okay um and i think from an
early age i i was fascinated by music
it's not that i am so talented in music
but i really enjoyed
listening and um and i studied a bit but
i
i enjoyed music and i had a
episode where i liked opera as a child
and wanted to be an opera singer so
i tried to do it around the house and
and
and obviously i was not too gifted in
that
aspect so it was it was not so enjoyable
for the
for the family members but it was a
period of time where i tried to sing
opera
i love it and what what inspires you
today
in your daily life um at the end i think
i like that each day is different from
the other
and and each day i need to address other
um things and sometimes it can be
relevant for external
to the company customers and suppliers
sometimes it's
a internal aspect hr
and other internal matters inside the
company sometimes it's financial
sometimes it's
sales and marketing so i really like the
diversity of everything
um and the need to all the time
um learn and reinvent myself
and have new challenges amazing and what
are three words that you would use to
describe yourself
uh i i hope at least that i
am for the good and for both i'm very
direct
and also with my my
team and my family of course um i have a
high expectation for myself and from
those that work with me and for my
family
um and i think that i'm a loyal and
honest i think wonderful hannah thank
you very very much toda
best of luck with kaka robotics and and
i look forward to seeing where this goes
and thank you for coming and sharing
this time with me i appreciate it